i'm always suss when someone says like
there's a really nice spot to travel to
in the uk because i'm just like
oh like why what like why would you
travel to the uk when you could travel
out of the uk and experience something
even nicer you know what i mean
people go around england and england are
just the same [ __ ] different places well
i went to england my first time and i
went to a beautiful town do you know
stoke on trent
he went to stoke-on-trent yeah this is
the same reaction i gave him
stoke-on-trent
lovely vacation there
where is it it's north of uh london yeah
why would you do that why why why why in
all of the uk did you choose i just
thought he loved
it i thought it'd be lovely and it
seemed like he's [ __ ] live he went
for a smash tournament
at the college
uh staffordshire you went all the way to
a a for a
smash tournament uh-huh was it worth it
no
no not i mean it was still fun but i
have i've definitely gone to like i used
to go to smash tournaments and that'd be
like my main reason to go somewhere yeah
like you guys with conventions right
right that's just what a smash
tournament is
but then i was like you know what
traveling is exhausting and i cannot do
youtube or stream when i'm doing it yeah
and i've i've gone away less i don't
know if you've noticed that with
conventions
it's like harder to sign up to go to one
yeah yeah i mean that's that's why we
[ __ ] took our equipment here so we
can work on the road yeah and make
content but other than that i mean i
think the reason we're traveling so much
this year is just because it's been like
two [ __ ] years of pandemic and we
just want to travel
um yeah but yeah we needed to get out
yeah right yeah we were like i've never
been like stir crazy in a country before
but that's how i felt after two years of
japan love japan i just miss
speaking english sometimes you know
right that was a massive thing
um but what was your experience of
british culture then
it was pretty chill uh you know the
tesco meal deal is great i went to a
casino everyone was really nice uh the
taxi drivers were way too comfortable
talking about doing cocaine
and
stoke on trend right yeah
outside of that just something to do
yeah yeah great we'll be back again 10
out of 10. nice indian spot cool
but certainly not my number one vacation
no well i don't have you been to like
london at all like you've seen london a
bit we went when we did the podcast with
ace of butterfield to london right uh
and that was that was chill but i also
find
like i i i went first day i went to
coventry to do a podcast with tommy and
i and i i feel bad when i'm just like
i'll just vacation and hang out yeah so
i didn't like do that i just worked the
whole time
i recorded super auto pets vods
in my hotel room for like a few hours
instead of going out was that the same
hotel that i said yeah yeah yeah dude
they did not have a desk how did you do
that uh the mine did mine had like a
little desk i could have a desk and i
was and i was just playing super auto
pets it was just a game
or just no just recorded why because
they did well on youtube and uh
so i but i don't feel like i should
permit myself to just you know just have
time to have a night on the town go get
your dreams why not like now's your sign
now so now he doesn't know much doesn't
that much pressure maybe i'm also i
think i think i'm anxious after kova to
just like go out to a pub alone and just
be like
oyoy and just when you're with your
friends no solo well next time you've
got to come to a cool city like brighton
no no no yeah come surprise brighton's
you're comparing it to what whales
they're like oh we've got like a seaside
and the beach is like mid it's like a
really mediocre beach i stayed in the
worst hotel of my life in brighton
really by far the worst hotel ever what
did you where did you stay it was the
one right next to the pier okay well you
don't stay near the pier you know but
it's like it's like this giant hotel and
the best location in brighton you'd
think it's this historical building and
somehow they just made this like just a
miserable experience just like i walked
into the room and it was just mold
everywhere and then you go to the
bathtub like i'll take a shower this
black [ __ ] all over the bathtub you're
like what the [ __ ] and they charged
money for this and then i went to boil
the cattle that's usually how hotels was
yeah
and so i went to boil the cattle to make
a cup of tea because at least if there's
one salvation life i can have a cup of
tea yeah i can have that i go there and
the coil in the kettle is just rust just
completely rusted and i'm like what the
f these are like five pounds to get the
shittest kettle because the hotel
kettles are the worst ones yeah this is
the british problem uh i can't believe
they deprive you of this
just a basic human right in the uk that
is a basic human yeah in the in the uk
the hotel room will have like they won't
have fridges but they'll always have a
catalyst
they will not provide toothbrush and
toothpastes
but they will happen they'll always have
a channel because you need tea yeah
you'll be in like a one-star hotel it's
like a like a [ __ ] mattress on the
floor and there'll be somehow a kettle
there you know we used to go to like
france right uh like
every year for like three weeks my mom
would always bring a kettle with her oh
because they don't have it in france
because they actually wanted to she want
to make tea yeah yeah and in france
you're just taking a shot of espresso
moving on with your just be rude to
someone on the street instead that's how
you get your kicks for the day yeah
yeah they're nice in southern france
maybe like outside of paris yeah yeah in
paris they're dicks but that's also the
charm like you want that no no i know
yeah it's like a it's like a fed you
want him to like spit on you and be
like just going to downtown man
experience you speak french i speak
french yeah so you probably had a better
time because you speak french
what will happen to me is because i
speak french but i speak kind of like a
seven-year-old and everyone in paris
speaks english so sometimes like it
depends but i'll speak french and then
they'll reply in english and i'll just
be like no because i i got i got denied
entry into a restaurant because i didn't
speak french oh that wouldn't happen to
me yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah that's
that's rude yeah yep probably racist
totally racist yeah
i think that's like the the definition
the definition of race guys are saying
like you want that like
well it's such a great experience part
of the chart yeah got kicked out i was
frothing at the mouth
right and sucks that was the main point
yeah that's fair i i disagree of course
i would well why wouldn't i right
brian's a natural cool city in the uk i
can't believe you're like digging on
bryce you've never been to wales huh
you've never been to wales what's in
wales you're gonna have a look cheap uh
it's actually this really cool youtuber
with ten thousand subs
he's my favorite they're gonna caught it
for that's right
that's not a tourist block just has like
a castle in the middle of the city how
[ __ ] sick is that this is a castle
can you go in it yeah oh then that's
cool yeah right i'm on board there's no
castles in brighton
there's like a rondael castle which is
like pretty damn close actually isn't it
destroyed
no it's working you can go in there
they're currently fighting out of it
right now yeah
casuals are either working or ruins
uh what's your thoughts on english
breakfast
i mean i love english breakfast i
wouldn't have it every day but it's true
oh wait you wouldn't have 2 000 calories
at 8 a.m every day it's too much you
know the heaven whale's actually the
best english breakfast ever in in wales
ironically
did i call it a welsh breakfast i try to
single-handedly double the tourism of
whales in this podcast there's this one
place uh near where i grew up and uh
it's just like it's a farm right and the
whole point is that all the farms come
together and they all bring their
produce to the store it's like a hipster
kind of thing and so they make their own
everything like baked beans i've never
seen homemade baked beans i didn't even
know it existed i thought heinz had the
monopoly yeah they've owned all the beef
i just thought you weren't it was like
illegal to make beans it didn't come in
the heinz can but now they made
everything fresh the egg yolk was so
amazing it was like bright red so raw it
was amazing mushrooms all fresh bread
was baked there bro it was game-changing
it sounds great i i can't have english
breakfast i mean that's communal right
like that's that's the that's the
penultimate breakfast you can yeah and
it was expensive but it was good it was
amazing
i mean like a british like english
breakfast is one of the few british
cuisines i'm actually proud of you know
there's no there's no there's not many
in england it's pretty [ __ ] good yeah
yeah but i just can't have it more than
three days in a row like shepherds and
cottage pie that's bad i mean i think
it's i think it's better than american
breakfast
no what's wrong with having 80 grams of
sugar date nine a.m what are you talking
about why why why did you guys trick
yourselves into eating dessert for
breakfast yeah why did you guys think
pancakes were breakfast food yeah it's
cause when you're a kid growing up
there's like a cute bunny and he's like
wow
eat my cereal
do you eat breakfast uh yeah i have a
protein shake and a banana wow i have a
boring breakfast that's pretty because
cereal is terrible for you yeah it's
awful and all you know having grand slam
years
but hey they go hard i do like uh like
pancakes protein pancakes what protein
pancakes yeah you can get like pancakes
that are like infused with like protein
powder oh so you get like glasses
different oil put proteins you can't
really tell because i lather peanut
butter on it i love peanut butter oh
right right so that's just my [ __ ] you
know what if they changed british
breakfast to be called english brunch
i'm on board well it's not meant to be
eaten traditionally as a breakfast oh
yes
english breakfast isn't no no no no when
is english breakfast meant to be eaten
connor okay lunch yeah basically you
have a night you need a late lunch you
need you need a hangover cure and that's
when that's you got to change the name
to brunch it's a marketing problem but
british people don't get brunch that's
like
they wouldn't understand the combination
of words